und dazu begrüße ich den spd obmann im
wirecard untersuchungsausschuss jens
zimmermann guten tag nach berlin bonn
aus hessen
dabei hätte man sie sind den hessen aber
in berlin werden um 10 uhr ihre kollegen
von der fdp den grünen und der
linkspartei eine zwischenbilanz der
bisherigen ausschussarbeit ziehen
nach allem was man hört werden die dem
spd geführten finanzministerium nicht
unbedingt zu hören ruhm verhelfen worauf
machen sie sich gefasst naja wir
verbringen jede woche ungefähr 30
stunden miteinander deswegen erwarte ich
da jetzt für mich persönlich keine
überraschungen
und es ist natürlich auch sechs monate
vor der bundestagswahl
wenige tage vor zwei landtagswahlen
jetzt keine überraschung wenn die
opposition an der bundesregierung da
jetzt kritik üben wird
insofern erwarte ich da jetzt erst mal
keine überraschung der opposition
gehören auch die grünen und die sagen
dank dieses untersuchungsausschusses
wisse man jetzt dass das
finanzministerium früher und
konsequenter hätte einschreiten können
und müssen auf was das verhalten der
bafin angeht an deren spitze habe olaf
scholz viel zu lange festgehalten
sagen sie und damit die neuaufstellung
verschleppt ist denn die brandmauer um
ihren also den spd-kanzlerkandidaten
stabil genug
ich glaube dieser untersuchungsausschuss
hat im wesentlichen jahr alles andere
außer um das finanzministerium herr oben
beleuchtet weil das bei diesem skandal
die finanzaufsicht eine rolle gespielt
hat und die frage natürlich im raum
steht was das finanzministerium getan
hat das haben wir letztes jahr im august
auch schon bewusst aber durch die arbeit
des untersuchungsausschusses wissen wir
eben jetzt dass dieser
wirtschaftsskandal viel viel breiter ist
die wirtschaftsprüfer die
staatsanwaltschaft die staatsregierung
in bayern und das lobbying aus dem
kanzleramt all das sind dinge die haben
wir vor dem untersuchungsausschuss nicht
gewusst und insofern braucht es
überhaupt keine brandmauer um das
finanzministerium sondern diese
transparenz die der
untersuchungsausschuss geschaffen hat
ermöglicht glaube ich am ende jetzt
allen sich einen eindruck zu machen was
wirklich passiert ist
olaf scholz hat ja durchaus schon fehler
bei der bafin bei der finanzaufsicht
eingeräumte will jetzt die
aufsichtsbehörde grundlegend reformieren
aber seinen gesetzentwurf zur reform der
bafin stößt praktisch bei allen parteien
außer der spd auf widerstand die
aufsichtsräte die müssten gestärkt
werden heißt es da aus der opposition
die abschlussprüfer müssten in kürzeren
abständen nicht erst nach zehn jahren
wechseln
sind sie denn zu nachbesserungen bei
diesem gesetz bereit
ja also da gilt das deutsche gesetz kein
gesetz verlässt den deutschen bundestag
so wie es reingekommen ist und ich habe
das natürlich mit sehr großem interesse
verfolgt das gerade von seiten der union
jetzt gesagt wurde man will dieses
geschätzten gesetz nachschärfen
es wurde ja von olaf scholz und
christine lambrecht vorgelegt und dann
in wirtschaftsministerium bei peter
altmaier wieder verbessert
deswegen muss ich da schon ein bisschen
schmunzeln wenn sich die union jetzt an
die spitze der aufklärung und erlauben
sie mir das als hesse der
brutalstmöglichen verbesserungen der
bafin jetzt da an die spitze stellen
insofern wir sind dafür offen
ich glaube die spd ist noch nie dafür
bekannt gewesen dass wir gegen schärfere
regulierung auf den finanzmärkten sind
und deswegen freue ich mich auch sehr
oft die beratungen im bundestag ihre
partei und die union wollen der die
zeugenvernehmung im ausschuss schon im
april abschließen die opposition pocht
allerdings darauf weitere sitzungen
was spricht eigentlich dagegen außer der
tatsache dass das thema was vielleicht
nicht so angenehm ist für den
finanzminister so stärker auch noch den
wahlkampf bestimmen würde also in dieses
ende der zeugenvernehmung das fällt
nicht vom himmel dass wir haben ende
juni die letzte sitzung des deutschen
bundestages und in dieser sitzung muss
der ausschuss dem plenum bericht
erstatten dieser bericht muss davor
erstellt werden dafür brauchen wir sechs
bis acht wochen
und wenn man das zurück rechnet ist man
ende april und das ist die ganze
geschichte wie es zu diesem termin kommt
es gab keinen untersuchungsausschuss in
den letzten 15 jahren der irgendwie
näher am ende der legislaturperiode noch
getagt hat als insofern ist das keine
verschwörung der koalitionsfraktionen
einfach die zeitlichen umstände des
endes der legislaturperiode im übrigen
haben wir das zeugen programm bis ende
april im untersuchungsausschuss jetzt
auch einvernehmlich so abgestimmt als
ich verstehe das heißt die opposition
nach draußen geht und hier ein wenig
poltert aber hinter verschlossenen türen
arbeiten wir da sehr gut zusammen und
wir haben uns darauf geeinigt am 24
april wird die kanzlerin die zeugen von
dem wenn die kanzlerin davor auch der
wirtschaftsminister hat immer mal
vielleicht aus aktuellem anlass schnell
noch ein wort zu einer causa die auch
den finanzausschuss des bundestages dem
sie angehören beschäftigen wird nämlich
die turbulenzen um die bremer greencell
bank da steht ja der verdacht der
bilanzmanipulation im raum schließen sie
sich den kritikern an die jetzt sagen
auch hier sei die bafin zu spät aktiv
geworden indizien dafür gibt es ja die
frage ist ob sie zu spät aktiv geworden
ist oder ob sie einfach die anlegerin
anleger nicht früh genug warnen konnte
wir wissen auch aus dem wirecard
untersuchungsausschuss dass die
gesetzeslage es momentan ganz ganz
schwer macht informationen weiterzugeben
weil an ganz vielen stellen
verschwiegenheitspflichten tatsächlich
im gesetz verankert sind und das ist
eigentlich glaube ich das größte problem
weil wenn die bafin da schon dran war
aber ihn nicht bannen konnte dann sehe
ich darin ein problem
es gibt aber natürlich das zweite thema
und das ist schon auch die frage gerade
was institutionelle anleger angeht also
ich meine städte und gemeinden die
teilweise jahr zweistellige
millionenbeträge dort geparkt haben bei
einer bank von der eigentlich noch nie
jemand etwas gehört hat und da muss man
natürlich auch muss es erlaubt sein die
frage zu stellen ob das von einigen
kamera die richtige entscheidung war und
da auch die notwendige sorgfalt gewalt
wurde
mal sehen was der sonderbeauftragte der
die bafin nach bremen geschickt hat
aufklären kann in dieser causa in der
tat die kommunen schauen mit großer
sorge dass oder auf das was da an der
weser im moment geschieht herz immer
wenn ich danke ihnen für diese auskünfte
und größe nach jetzt richtig hessen
vielen dank